Lleva más de 30 años dedicada a la
apicultura y es la primera vez que las
abejas no están siendo productivas no
hay duda las colonias están sufriendo
los efectos de la deforestación
ocasionada por la construcción del tren
maya en la selva de la Península de
Yucatán en el sureste mexicano qué es lo
que observamos las abejas tienen una
situación de yo les digo que están
desnutridas no tienen el mismo nutriente
no tiene la misma fuerza no tienen la
misma
Vamos a decir que la energía para
reproducirse desde su inicio el tren
Maya enfrentado más de 25 amparos de
asociaciones y organismos del medio
ambiente que buscan la suspensión de la
obra uno de los tramos más polémicos es
el cinco ubicado entre Tulum y Playa del
Carmen en el Estado Sureño de Quintana
Roo porque atraviesa y amenaza largos
tramos de Selva virgen que han sido
deforestados sistemas de Cuevas que se
han derrumbado con las maquinarias y
flujos hídricos que han sido alterados
he visto cenotes en los que buceado que
ya no existen
este se nota donde estamos ahora
está condenado está moribundo
va a morir no hemos fallado en salvarlo
la selva que quitaron de aquí la selva
que yo conocí que estaba arriba de este
cenote ya no está pues es del tribunal
internacional de los derechos de la
naturaleza constataron las violaciones
al medio ambiente y notaron la
afectación a cientos de especies que
viven aquí la selva maya
como que agoniza como que
dice pide auxilio pide auxilio al mundo
a los ecologistas a la comunidad
científica que intervenga y a las Cortes
internacionales para decir que pare esto
el gobierno de México con este proyecto
insignia intenta construir 1.550
kilómetros de vía de ferrocarril a
través de cinco estados del sureste del
país y su meta es inaugurado en
diciembre de 2023 desde grandes
depredadores como el jaguar Hasta los
más pequeños como las abejas están
resintiendo el atropello del tren que
aún no pasa pero que ya deja sentir sus
efectos